visually speaking the rumbling might
possibly be the best ever opening we've
had for attack on titan and in this
video i'll be explaining all the small
details you might have missed including
hidden references and easter eggs in
certain key moments
if you're new to the channel then i'd
really appreciate if you hit that sub
button before we get into it as i have a
ton of explaining videos as well as
weekly episode breakdowns that i'm doing
for part two of the final season
okay so the opening starts off with
aaron tying up his hair and putting on
his jacket which is a call back to two
memorable scenes from part one in the
original scene when aaron tied his hair
this was at a time when the whole world
won a revenge against parodies and for
that reason he reminded himself in the
mirror that they need to fight if they
want to survive of course the only way
this tiny island can fight back is with
the rumbling hence why this moment comes
at the very beginning it symbolizes
aaron's intention to destroy everyone
outside the walls and the same is true
when it comes to this jacket reference
since in the original scene his goal in
that moment was to begin the rumbling by
finding zeke
a few seconds later the opening actually
shows us the rumbling in action with the
colossal footprint stepping onto a
neighborhood in mali this results in a
shock wave that pulsates through the
street and the shattered glass and dust
that followed was a nice touch
we then see that as the titans continue
to march the colour of the sky keeps on
changing to subtly demonstrate that they
keep moving forward regardless of the
time of day
back in season 2 it was heavily implied
by nick that these titans only had
energy to move in the sunlight just like
most other pure titans however this clip
makes it very clear that light isn't
really a factor
we then get this screenshot here which
is a reference to chapter 131 of the
manga and that chapter was simply titled
rumbling on this page a bunch of
innocent refugees were about to escape
by running towards the high ground but
this idea was quickly ruined after
realizing that titans could climb
mountains and this is visible in the
background of the screenshot
things then transitioned to one of the
most meaningful cuts of the entire
opening involving both air and zeke and
the ocean as we know for years it was
aaron's dream to reach the ocean and
explore the outside because his idea of
freedom was a world where he wasn't
confined inside the walls by titans
however by the time he achieved this
dream he began to understand this wasn't
true freedom as long as there were
enemies across the sea who wanted to
kill them therefore the ocean appearing
in this moment is meant to symbolize
aaron's desire for freedom at any cost
whether that be his new version of
freedom which involves destroying
everything on the other side of the sea
anyway during this scene a shot of zeke
and aaron then briefly appears and this
honestly signifies so many different
things
firstly the dna in the background is a
reference to chapter 137 when zeke
talked about how the nature of life is
to pointlessly multiply without ever
knowing if existence has any meaning
this ties into his core belief that the
eldian race should be euthanized which
is something aaron is obviously against
hence why the two brothers are facing
away from each other instead of towards
each other not only does aaron want the
alien race to continue but he's willing
to sacrifice billions of humans around
the planet just to make sure that can
happen so these two really are complete
opposites
the blood in the background might be
referencing the fact that zeke has royal
blood but at the same time it might also
be alluding to the fact that they are
connected by the blood of their father
after the title appears the opening then
focuses on aaron again as you can see
there are a bunch of birds flying around
him as he walks on top of the wall ever
since the very first chapter there's
always been a subtle connection when it
came to aaron and birds and that's
because burst had the freedom to venture
outside the walls and go to any of the
places they read about in arma's
grandpa's book the survey caused wings
of freedom logo is also the ultimate
confirmation that birds represent
freedom so it makes perfect sense why
there are so many of them around him on
a separate note the idea of eren being
reincarnated as a bird is a theory that
has been jokingly mentioned since the
end of the series but i actually think
aaron would be lucky if that theory
turned out to be true the way i see it
he's either stuck in hell or stuck in
the past dimension making shifters for a
new generation so either way i'd say
being a bird is likely the best option
he could hope for
the opening then gives us a comparison
between how things used to be versus how
they are now with an example being how
it shows marco sasha and the rest of the
104th cadets before flashing forward to
the day of sasha's funeral it does this
again when it shows us berto annie and
rainer only to flash forward to the
present day in mali where reiner is the
only warrior who made it back alive by
this point in the timeline bertolt is
dead and he's imprisoned underground and
ymir who was in this flashback has now
been eaten by poco meanwhile colton the
other warriors watch on as gabby and
falco play together although zeke is
noticeably not there
this moment is followed by shots of levi
and hanji and this is by far the most
depressed the captain has ever looked
during an opening usually if he makes an
appearance it's just him showing off or
looking cool but in this one there's
blood splattered across his face as he
looks up towards the sky a lot of his
frustration in part two comes from the
fact that he still hasn't fulfilled his
promise to kill the beast titan and on
top of that zeke took advantage by
detonating the thunderspear which has
now left the captain weaker than he's
been for a long time
speaking of zeke he then gets his time
to shine and there were a few easter
eggs in this moment it starts off with a
young version of the character playing
catch with sava and it was this game
that led to z becoming such a good
pitcher something that he then used his
advantage as the beast titan the opening
itself directly references this by
transitioning from yangzi throwing a
baseball at sava to adults eat throwing
rocks after inheriting salva's titan
following this there's been a quick shot
of him regenerating which is likely a
throwback to the first episode of part 2
when pretty much his entire body was
rebuilt from scratch thanks to yamir
fritz
one thing worth pointing out about this
whole zeke sequence is that there was a
tree in this shot of him playing catch
there was a different tree in this shot
of him throwing the ball and then there
were even more trees in this shot of him
regenerating this imagery is likely
referring to the tree which contained
the source of all living matter since
that tree was the origin of all these
problems if it wasn't for yamir fritz
falling into this tree then no subjects
of emir would have ever been born so if
you think about it zeke has basically
spent his whole adult life trying to
reverse the impact that this tree had on
the world
as a side note he actually came up with
the idea for the euthanization plan
while playing catch with sarva so it is
fitting that all of these moments were
included in zeke's sequence
anyhow the opening then immediately
switches from zeke to a clip of erin
biting his hand which i guess is another
way of showing that he's ready to fight
against this euthanization ideology
after he bites his hand there's a flash
of white light to indicate his titan
transformation and the next thing we see
is the attack titan about to beat up
reiner in a moment that again references
the first episode of part 2.
the sequence then goes on to show us
moments from all the different warriors
with pique looking absolutely exhausted
her extreme level of tiredness is
because the malian army makes her stay
in the car titan for months at a time
and earlier in the season she'd been in
there for so long that she physically
needed support to stand up as a result
her being exhausted in this screenshot
is pretty appropriate for her character
and is followed by an action shot of the
cart titan with its special cannon
after that we move on to porco as he
stares outside the window and in the
reflection is ymir the connection
between these two characters is unusual
considering that she ate his brother but
then willingly allowed herself to be
taken back to mali so she could be eaten
by him her sacrifice allowed poco to
finally become a warrior after he was
robbed of the title all those years ago
and in one sense you could tell he was
grateful to her for choosing to come
back thanks to amir's memories he was
also able to see what really happened on
the island firsthand which is likely
what he was thinking about while her
reflection was on the window
annie was the next warrior to get some
of the spotlight and surprisingly the
opening shows her outside of the crystal
this was definitely one of the biggest
spoilers in the whole thing however
given that annie being released from her
crystal is a direct consequence of the
rumbling you can understand why they
would want to show it
in this clip she couldn't have been free
for very long since she's still
underground and covered in that titan
fluid so this moment helps to fill in
the gap between the crystal being
destroyed and her confronting hitch
the female titan itself then makes a
brief appearance before switching to
bertolt who is inside his colossal titan
bertolt's appearance coming immediately
after annie was likely done on purpose
due to all those feelings he had for her
and as we know these feelings were
seemingly passed on to armin
in this clip a bloody tear falls down
bertel's sheik which then quite
literally gives life to armin as he
opens his eyes and besides receiving
life the tear possibly also represents
the memories and emotions that he
inherited
a small detail is that the tear came out
of bertolt's right eye specifically
which has happened in at least two
separate visions that armin has seen
throughout the series
the next bit of imagery is the new
colossal titan standing over the
destruction he caused in liberio and the
scene then transitions to inside the
internment zone here we see the
warhammer in the same pose it made
before decapitating the attack titan
only in this opening before aaron's head
gets cut off it switches to him with his
hands around the warhammer crystal
during the episode in which he ate lara
tiber he literally held the crystal in
his hand from start to finish looking
for different ways to break it so i
think this image is symbolizing his
determination to steal this power let's
not forget that he also ate willy tyber
who appeared to be the most obvious
candidate to have the warhammer so
clearly this shifter is something aaron
was on a mission to get
following this we finally move over to
the past dimension and at the beginning
of this sequence the focus is mainly on
the sand this sand is what emirates used
for over 2 000 years to create the
bodies of every pure titan and every
titan shifter and as we saw with zeke it
can also be used to rebuild the flesh of
aldians when in their human form the
camera then pans up to show us the
coordinate which is where the paths
connecting all subjects of emir converge
into one every single branch on the
coordinate represents the bloodlines of
emea's descendants and it's no
coincidence that it looks like a tree
when we consider the origin of our titan
powers
a flashback to her backstory then
flickers on screen as we see the bloody
flower that first appeared in chapter
122.
in that chapter yamir's blood dripped
onto this flower after these elden
soldiers kept shooting her with arrows
and in episode 16 of the final season a
similar flower happened to appear next
to zeke when he was nearly about to die
in both situations when this flower
appeared the characters in question
thought this was going to be the end but
were then miraculously saved by the
power of the titans
in yamir's case the opening shows us her
reaction to being touched by the source
of all living matter hence why she
starts to glow in this moment because
she's acquiring her titan abilities
another flash of light then appears
followed by a glimpse of the clouds and
this is a reference to both aaron and
falco
in chapter 133 falco saw the memory of a
previous beast titan flying above the
clouds and this was his first
realization that his draw titan might be
able to fly as well
at the same time the clouds have
significance to aaron too because the
sights he can see from up there are what
he always thought freedom would look
like that's why the opening shows him
looking over the clouds in amazement
before morphing into a younger version
of the character
a knife then appears next to him and the
reason it shows up at this moment was
pretty brilliant in my opinion
back when the jaeger brothers were
looking inside their father's memories
aaron said to zeke that if someone is
willing to take his freedom then he
wouldn't hesitate to take theirs and at
the time he was talking about how he
used the knife to attack meeks's
kidnappers however in this opening his
words take on a whole new meaning
because he's willing to take the freedom
of everyone outside the island so that
aliens on the island can be free
in between this section there's also
visuals of cannons being fired into the
ocean and this is a nod to how the
global alliance tried to fight back
against the titans swimming towards them
this fleet was meant to be the strongest
weapons humanity had to offer but in the
end they were easily brushed aside like
it was nothing
following that we see a bunch of aliens
in liberia looking up as the rumbling
heads towards them and in the corner you
can see the local town drunk who was
bizarrely already killed in the first
half of the season i'm not exactly sure
why he was resurrected for this opening
but just to be clear this guy never
actually survived to see the rumbling in
action
many of the scouts didn't appear on top
of the walls as silhouettes and from
what i can tell you've got yamir and
historia on the left arm and aaron and
mikasa in the middle the three warriors
on the right and then sasha connie and
jean filling the remaining places
mikasa then throws her scarf over her
shoulder and i probably don't need to
explain that this scarf means everything
to her i mean even till the end she was
still wearing it as it all ties back to
erin being her savior
erin gave her this scarf at a time when
she had no parents and basically nowhere
to live so tamika sir this scarf
symbolizes family it symbolizes home it
gives her strength and in uncertain
times it reminds her that aaron is a
good person
inside the walls of shiganchina they
both race towards a tree with armin
which is a reference to the final volume
cover and also chapter 137
in that chapter armin explained to zeke
that the reason they were born wasn't
just to multiply and that maybe the
purpose of life can be found in these
trivial precious moments like racing
towards that tree on the hill
the three friends are then seen facing
the tree together before mikasa and
armin disappear which is basically a
symbol for how aaron has been alone ever
since that day he kisses storia's hand
armin even explicitly says this in the
final chapter because ever since aaron
saw those fragments of the future he was
put in a position where he had to follow
the path that was laid out for him and
if he had told anyone what he saw then
that would have messed everything up
in the opening he then briefly evolves
into hobo erin and i'll explain why this
version of the character is so
significant
in part one we saw that for a couple of
years after he kissed his story his hand
he still wasn't 100 sure if the future
he saw was guaranteed to happen and for
a while he thought there might be
another way for the people of the island
to survive however hobo aaron is the
first real version of the character who
understood there could be no
alternatives and that the destiny he saw
was inescapable the opening demonstrates
this by zooming into his eye which is
basically their way of showing us what
aaron saw and inside his mind we can see
his founding titan form standing behind
the army of war titans he unleashed
in this shot we have a nice visual of
just how large his founder really is
compared to the titans underneath him
and as i mentioned in my video about all
founding titans the design of his
shifter is based off the source of all
living matter
a steamy aaron then regenerates as he
screams on top of the walls in a moment
that's possibly a throwback to the very
first time he activated the coordinate
his scream in this opening might be
signifying his frustration at having to
follow this path because we know from
the final chapter that he didn't want to
die in the end but he had no choice but
to go along with it since that's what
was destined to happen
on top of that we know the founder was
messing with his perception of reality
as he was experiencing the past present
and future all at the same time so this
scream right here might just be him
going a little bit insane
towards the very climax of the opening a
wall titan steps onto the ground leaving
a bloody footprint behind and this is
definitely a reference to ramsay ramsay
was a young refugee living in mali who
was crushed in chapter 131 and this
footprint is nearly identical to the one
that killed the young refugee
ramsay had more significance to the
story than most rumbling victims as when
aaron saw the future he actually saw a
vision of this kid and then tearfully
apologized to him in the two cross paths
in mali
the scene then cuts to a butterfly
trample by a regular shoe and this part
is meant to emphasize that the world has
always been a cruel place where the
winners survive when the losers die
which is an observation mikasa made a
long long time ago
as a child she witnessed this cruelty on
a much smaller scale but now because of
the rumbling that same cruelty that's
always existed is being dished out to
billions across the globe
now switching over to the lyrics of this
opening there were a couple lines from
the song that i thought were pretty
interesting for example towards the
beginning there was a line that said all
i wanted to do was the right things i
never wanted to be the king and this
perfectly summarizes eren at the
beginning when he thought the entire
world was just the people inside the
walls he wanted to do the right thing by
exterminating the titans and making sure
the sacrifice of all previous scouts
wasn't in vain he never intended to end
up as this all-knowing or powerful being
and given the choice it's highly
doubtful he would have taken it if he
knew what was about to happen if we take
a more literal approach to the lyrics i
never wanted to be the king might also
be a reference to him rejecting carl
fritz's ideology who was the lda king
that established that vow to renounce
war the vow to announce war is directly
opposed to everything aaron has ever
believed because as we know everyone who
was affected by the bow was okay with
the island being destroyed by either the
titans or mali
there was another line that said if i
lose it all outside the wall live to die
another day which is solid confirmation
of the bird reincarnation theory no but
in all seriousness i thought this lyric
was good because aaron is known for the
longest time that he was destined to die
outside the walls in fact he was putting
things in motion to make sure that would
happen so the line left to die another
day could mean this might not be the end
the past dimension has been referred to
by armin and zeke as a world free of
death and like i alluded to earlier the
final panel of the series does imply the
error might be stuck in there just by
himself
anyway people those rule the easter eggs
and references i could find for this
opening and if you liked the video then
i'd appreciate if you dropped a like and
subs if you haven't already
thanks for watching as always and until
the next one
peace out